where you at Beyonce my eyes are wet
you changed my life lizzo in tears over
Beyonce during her Grammy's acceptance
speech I'm feeling good as hell
yeah and to No Surprise the singer's
love for queen bee goes way back
everything
finally your
lizzo took home her fourth Grammy Sunday
night winning record of the year for her
song about damn time
first she dedicated her trophy to her
Idol and former Mentor Prince whom she
worked with before his death in 2016.
when we lost Prince I decided to
dedicate my life to making positive
music the end of lizzo's speech was
dedicated to her hero Beyonce that's
when things got emotional Beyonce
in the fifth grade I skipped school to
see you perform
school it was literature I'm good
and um where are you at Beyonce my eyes
are wet
you changed my life you choose saying
that gospel medley and the way you made
me feel I was like I want to make people
feel this way with my music so thank you
so much you clearly are the artists of
Our Lives
I love you I'm just blessed it's no
secret that lizzo's part of the Beehive
I mean she's like the one for me you
know I love her so freaking much I'm
from Houston I watched Destiny's Child
on the rise watching Destiny's Child in
the fifth grade inspired me to be a
singer
I'm not gonna give up but this is hardly
a one-way Street blame it on the juice
baby she was at my show and I did I
never met her did you know she was there
I didn't all I saw was like a um like a
Celestial being okay but I didn't know
that it was Beyonce so I just kept
performing I was like something's
different this time right and I looked
at my DJ I was like this is crazy for
some weird reason and then afterwards
they were like yeah Beyonce and Jay-Z
were just bopping to your whole set and
I was numb but lizzo isn't the only
Grammy winner who used their record of
the Year accepted speech to praise Queen
B let me tell you something me and Adele
having a good time just enjoying
ourselves just rooting for our friends
Russo's paladel did it back in 2017 when
the British singer took home the award
Overby who was also nominated in the
same category my idol is queen bee and I
adore you
and I am you move my soul every single
day and you have done for nearly 17
years I adore you and I want you to be
my mummy the reason I felt the need to
say something was my album of the year
is lemonade
[Music]
she is my icon of my whole life the good
news here is that lizzo Adele and
Beyonce were all big winners at the 65th
Grammy Awards but despite all those
shiny Trophies the biggest prize getting
in that quality girl time the singer
simply captioned this pic with the
ladies I won what's next world
domination
foreign